we start again today with non-trump
stuff there is lots of news to discuss
and a blockbuster story about Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas breaking
from propublica about his acceptance of
all sorts of high-value goodies from a
billionaire Republican possibly criminal
certainly unethical and we will discuss
it now we've had our suspicions about
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
not only did his tenure on the Supreme
Court start Under This Cloud of
allegation of sexual harassment we also
have seen this unbelievable story in
which he was presiding and potentially
presiding over cases related to the 2020
election as we knew that his wife Ginny
Thomas was an activist for the Biden
stole IT Crowd that was all wrapped up
and wide win in with the rioters of
January 6 2021. so and then you know 20
years in between that you can fill in
with other
red flags and question marks well there
has never been anything like this in
Supreme Court history in terms of
receiving gifts there's a fantastic
propublica piece that you can look at we
are going to look at a tweet thread from
propublica that gives us all of the most
important highlights and it starts for
decades judge Clarence Thomas Thomas has
secret secretly accepted luxury trips
from a major Republican donor newly
obtained documents show Thomas has
publicly presented presented himself as
an every man with modest tastes in this
documentary about him he waxes nostalgic
about his fondness for Walmart parking
lots but and this is one of those great
buts but Thomas's friendship with
dallas-based real estate magnate Harlan
Crowe has allowed him to repeatedly
experience luxuries well beyond his
means he's vacationed on Crow's 162 Foot
super yacht around the globe and flies
on Crows Bombardier Global 5000 jet
that's a nice jet nice jet if you can
get one in June of 2019 Thomas boarded
Crow's private jet to Indonesia for nine
days of island hopping on the yacht
had Thomas chartered the Jet and Yacht
himself could have set him back half a
million dollars it wasn't Thomas's first
time on Crow's yacht the Michaela Rose
he went on a river day in Savannah a
river day trip in Savannah Georgia and
an extended Cruise in New Zealand about
a decade ago while sailing around New
Zealand with Crow he autographed a copy
of his Memoir as a gift for a crew
member
by the way that that's quite a
narcissistic move thank you so much
here's my book the justice has gone with
Crow to the Bohemian Grove the exclusive
California all-male retreat and to
Crow's sprawling Texas ranch every
summer Thomas typically spends about a
week at Camp Top Ridge Crow's private
Resort in the Adirondacks inside the top
Ridge hangs a photorealistic painting of
one of Thomas's visits to the property
the painting shows Thomas enjoying a
cigar alongside Crow and chatting with
conservative power Brokers like Leonard
Leo if Leo's name sounds familiar it's
because the longtime Federalist Society
executive is regarded as an architect of
the Supreme Court's turn to the right
and recently received 1.6 billion
dollars for a new conservative political
group wow what Brazen cronyism and
Corruption
uh this continues and you can read all
of it uh I think the the important part
here is as follows
while Thomas and Crow have a genuine
friendship these vacations put the
Justice in contact with corporate
Executives and political activists
during just one July 2017 trip Thomas's
fellow guests included Executives at
Verizon
pricewaterhousecoopers major Republican
donors one of the leaders of the
conservative American Enterprise
Institute these trips appear nowhere on
Thomas's Financial disclosures where
justices are required to list most gifts
this is where we start to get into
potential criminality Pro publica looked
at flight records internal documents and
interviews with dozens of people to
uncover the travel details the failure
to report the flights appears to violate
a federal disclosure law passed after
Watergate by accepting the trips Thomas
has also broken on standing norms for
judges conduct ethics experts say
Nancy gertner a retired federal judge
says it's incomprehensible to me that
someone would do this Virginia cantor a
former government ethics lawyer who has
served in administrations of both
parties says Thomas quote seems to have
completely disregarded his higher
ethical obligations Thomas did not
respond to detailed questions so without
question this corrupts public trust and
justices are supposed to abide by a
higher ethical obligation in which not
only should you avoid
actual bias and partiality you should
avoid even the appearance of it and
there are a couple of different stories
here one is that Clarence Thomas and his
wife have a long history of political
entanglements with absolutely no
accountability we've known that for a
long time
secondly we have another Law and Order
story where my guess is and we'll have
to wait and see my guess is that right
Wingers will immediately Rush with
knee-jerk reactions to defend Clarence
Thomas and say these are paperwork
crimes just like Trump saw paperwork
crimes and everybody's all paperwork
crimes or whatever the case may be so
there will be no uh consistency there
and then lastly
is Clarence Thomas like this desperate
to be participating in this sort of
stuff that like it almost feels like you
know a yacht cruise and a trap to some
degree it all seems kind of pathetic as
well but now going from just the
suspicion of lack of Ethics to what
seems like bona fide a criminality the
violations of law as re as it regards
these Financial disclosures will it go
anywhere I don't know with Clarence
Clarence Thomas has had a sort of Teflon
status quo much like Donald Trump did
for many years although hopefully the
latter is ending with this week's arrest
that's the latest really great report uh
from propublica Good News out of
Michigan we're under the leadership of
Democratic governor Gretchen Whitmer
Michigan has repealed an insane 1931
abortion ban this is really wacky stuff
um did the Detroit Free Press reports
Whitmer repeals Michigan's 1931 abortion
ban with the stroke of her pen Governor
Gretchen Whitmer repealed an
unenforceable Michigan law Wednesday
that makes it a felony to administer
most abortions with no exception for
rape or incest now unenforceable
unenforceable is a critical word here
and so the reason to do this is less
about the idea that that law would start
to be enforced right now but the idea
that it could be enforced depending on
what cons continues to happen at the
highest court of the land the Supreme
Court in the United States and this is a
very very good thing
um it is important to understand that
this is only the beginning of what is
certain to be a much longer uh I guess
we would call it Crusade against
abortion that started decades ago with
the passage of Roe v Wade Roe v Wade uh
uh was about ensuring right to an
abortion but it triggered the battle
against abortion from the American right
they had a major success recently when
the Supreme Court did away with Roe v
Wade and we know that it is only the
beginning here is Governor Gretchen
Whitmer officially signing a repeal of
that abortion ban
all right
all right so most of us understand what
it looks like to sign a piece of paper
and here is Gretchen Whitmer actually
saying something about this just ahead
of the signing I don't ever want someone
from the
prize
we know that the decision when and
whether or not to Bear a child is most
consequential decision economically that
a family or a woman will make in her
lifetime the government has no business
getting in the way of conversations
between women and their doctors this
should not really be controversial but
it's did send the American right into a
tizzy hurling the term marxistic
Gretchen Whitmer I I don't know why I
don't know why getting rid of an insane
law from 1931 makes you a Marxist in
2023 I don't think they know either I
don't think they know what Marxist even
means but that doesn't matter because
what we do see is their passion if you
want to use that word
for making it as difficult as possible
to get an abortion under any
circumstances and anywhere in the United
States and so this is a small step again
at this point this was an unenforceable
1931 law but it is still important to
get these laws off the books and many
states particularly red states have
these retrograde ancient laws on the
books even if they aren't being enforced
right now any one of these that can be
taken off the table in terms of possible
future enforcement should be considered
a win and remember Governor Gretchen
Whitmer easily easily winning
re-election in November despite a
challenge from Trump endorsed Maga
candidate Tudor Dixon who went down in
flames and we can all be very very happy
about that we'll continue following this
fight for just simple medical rights
that's what we're talking about here
we'll take a break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube Channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
program we have for you today this one's
good enough that we might actually
record it
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below the David Pacman show is an
audience funded program if you
appreciate the work that we do I welcome
you to sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code indicted or you can
use the coupon code indicated in case
you accidentally or deliberately
misspell indicted the way Donald Trump
did indicated the coupon code will still
work you'll get access to the Daily
bonus show commercial free audio and
video streams of the show invitations to
member-only town halls as well as access
to the sound board it mirrors my
soundboard that I have here David
packman does not have a soul he doesn't
have a soul right that soundboard you
have access to as a member as well you
can sign up at joinpakman.com coupon
codes indicted or indicated Marjorie
Taylor green did something which had it
been done by Alexandria ocasio-cortez
they would be calling for her head would
it Marjorie Taylor green do
well she went on Tucker Carlson's Fox
news program
and just assailed New York City saying
it's disgusting saying it's dirty saying
it smells bad that people are dying from
drugs on the street and all of this is
because Marjorie Taylor green is furious
that on Tuesday she went and tried to
have a protest in support of Donald
Trump in the context of trump being
arrested on Tuesday in New York City and
she was run out of the place just run
out of the place whistles you couldn't
even hear what she was saying nobody
wanted her there more media than
supporters and so now she says it's
disgusting and it's disastrous and it's
all horrible just imagine if this was
AOC saying it about a city in Marjory
Taylor Green's District here is what she
had to say to Tucker Carlson and as it
won't shock you that Tucker Carlson
looks concerned and confused which is
generally always the look on his face
really quick since you were just there
but mayor Adams described New York as
quote his home how did his home look
pretty neat and tidy
no his home is disgusting I compared it
to what I called Gotham City the streets
are filthy they're covered with people
basically dying on drugs they can't even
stand up they're falling over there's so
much crime in the city I can't I can't
comprehend how people live there it was
repulsive it smells bad and I just I
think it's a terrible place
there's a lot that we could say here I'm
not even going to delve into the reality
that there's an opioid epidemic that is
in the south of the United States
there's a meth epidemic I mean listen
there's there are addiction problems in
all sorts of parts of this country and
Marjorie Taylor Green's part of the
country isn't exempt but understand that
this is her anger because her protests
lasted two and a half minutes before she
was just run out of there by hecklers
because nobody wanted her in New York
City we don't want Marjorie Taylor green
back in New York and it sounds like from
what she's saying we shouldn't expect to
see her again but it's really important
also to point out
that the entire New York City is
disgusting meme is pretty played out the
truth is that New York City has a lower
crime rate than many other cities in the
United States including cities run by
Republicans like Oklahoma City and even
some cities in Marjory Taylor greens
never mind Marjorie Taylor Green's State
Marjorie Taylor Green's District which
we are going to get to it's not really
groundbreaking news that when there is a
high population density sometimes you
see more trash in different places and
this of course applies to any place that
has uh that number of people it's not
really groundbreaking it doesn't really
say much about Eric Adams but just think
for a second
if AOC
went on MSNBC and said I went down to I
don't know I'm not going to pick on I'm
not picking on Dalton Georgia but Dalton
Georgia is in Marjory Taylor Green's
District I went down Rachel Maddow AOC
tell us what was it like down in Marjory
Taylor Green's District I went down to
Dalton Georgia
and the crime rate is way higher than
New York City it was disgusting the
average income per capita isn't even 22
000 there's no jobs there's no money
it's filled with these dirty textile
polluting industry buildings only 70
percent of the population in Dalton even
has a high school diploma compared to 85
percent in New York City it was terrible
disgusting place
imagine if AOC did that on MSNBC about
Dalton AOC and everyone on the right
would be saying they constantly insult
our part of the country they think that
we're stupid they think this they think
that they think we're backwards imagine
how the right would be reacting if AOC
had done what Marjorie Taylor green did
about New York City but there's a
difference the difference is that it's
now popular
to say this sort of stuff about New York
City even when you're not really
breaking any new grounds so the real
disgusting aspect to this is Marjorie
Taylor green that's what I find truly
deplorable not Manhattan which is not
exactly a hellscape the way she makes it
out to be
now it is not only Jim Jordan calling
for the police to be defunded
it is failed former president Donald
Trump yes indeed yes indeed what am I
talking about well I will show you
Donald Trump now in the wake of his uh
arrest is calling for the federal police
to be defunded he had the following to
say on his platform truth social quote
rep this isn't all caps by the way
republicans in Congress should defund
the doj and FBI until they come to their
senses the Democrats have totally
weaponized law enforcement in our
country and are viciously using this
abusive power to interfere with our
already Under Siege elections Trump
doesn't like the fact that he was
arrested by the way not by federal
prosecutors
and he is now calling for Congress to
pull funding from doj and FBI that is
that that's police that's law
enforcement that's federal law
enforcement and of course laws for the
and not for me has always been the
Republican way it's really important to
understand that when Trump says when he
talks about they should come to their
senses what he means is I should be
allowed to do whatever I want with no
consequence but nobody else should and
as I've told you before their stated
principles mean nothing oh we do we
support the police no you don't you
support the police to the extent that
it's convenient
when it came to the police officers
Capitol Police on January 6 2021 all of
a sudden they weren't the heroes the
hero was Ashley Babbitt
all of a sudden now it's not about fund
the police it's defund the police and
remember that on Sunday Jim Jordan said
the exact same thing to Maria bartiroma
legislation write laws and pass
legislation so we'll look at that and
maybe most importantly Maria is we
control the power of the purse and
that's we're gonna have to look at the
Appropriations process and limit funds
going to some of these agencies
particularly the ones who are engaged in
the most egregious Behavior so the doj
and the FBI
yeah and and what I'd really like
frankly legislation the doj and the FBI
it's not just one person anymore these
are the folks who have been slamming the
left for years saying you all want to
defund the police and I look around I
looked I looked under my phone and maybe
under my glass so why I can't find
anybody other than random voices on
Twitter who want to defund the police no
serious Democrats want to defund the
police there's no serious movement to
defund the police do some of us want to
reform restructure absolutely change
training protocol 100 percent
demilitarize of course but there is no
big movement to defund the police except
people like Jim Jordan
and Donald Trump and all of their
acolytes and suck-ups are now saying oh
doj and FBI we have to defund them oh
okay so when you say they want to defund
the police you really mean you want to
defund the police and what is
interesting to see is that at least for
now Republican voters don't seem to be
going for it let's take a look at that
Steve Ducey on Fox and Friends yesterday
morning had a cringy moment in which
they brought on a panel of
um Republicans I guess these are
and asked you know Trump now is saying
defund the doj defund the FBI does
anybody here think that that's a good
idea and not a single hand went up take
a look at this I love this stuff I
really do apparently today Donald Trump
has uh call
America to defund the police
particularly the FBI the Department of
Justice uh because the Democrats have
weaponized law enforcement right all
right who in this panel raise your hand
who thinks that's a good idea
all right nobody
[Laughter]
so listen obviously six people aren't
representative of the entire Republican
party this is more about the Optics of a
total backfire on TV which of course
triggers Trump even further and this has
the same Vibe as when Fox News hosted a
town hall for Bernie Sanders and the
audience applauded a lot of Bernie
Sanders ideas and it really didn't go
the way that that fox wanted it to go
from a narrative perspective so I think
there's a couple different things here
there are multiple passes that we often
take at this stuff right now there are
plenty of Republican voters who believe
we shouldn't defund the police and
believe that Democrats want to defund
the police and don't believe that
Republicans want to defund the police
and when presented with hey Trump's
trying to defund the police or he wants
to defund federal police they go no no
no that's bad this is wave one but you
have to understand that this is a cult
now whether these six people are part of
the call or not we don't actually know
but much of the Trump cult event will
just change their tune why well because
this is one of the characteristics of
Cults and we'll talk about some of the
other characteristics later today one of
the characteristics of Cults is
consistency doesn't matter
the consistency of the message that you
believe from your cult leader doesn't
matter it can change overnight and you
simply change your thinking and the cult
leader is Justified if they move on to
yes support local police but federal
police has been weaponized as a
political tool against Republicans only
so the FBI and the doj must be defunded
they will just adjust their view that
the double standard doesn't matter the
about face doesn't matter and this is
one of the characteristics of Cults you
hear a from the from the dear leader and
you follow it and the next day the
leader says not a and you say oh we're
following that and their word is perfect
and their word is divine almost like a
pseudo deity so yeah good for these six
people I guess I mean they they don't
want to defund the police for now but a
large number of trump supporters have
already come around to this side and
many more probably will as well all of
the clips that I played for you here you
can find not only on our YouTube channel
but also on our Instagram by searching
for David packman show and increasingly
popular more than 30 million views last
month on Tick Tock alone if you're into
the tick tock you can find us there at
davidpackman show we'll take a quick
break and be back with much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Erica engelhopt who's a science
journalist living in Washington DC and
also author of the book gory details
Adventures from the Dark Side of science
Eric a really great having you on I
appreciate it
thanks nice to be here so you know we've
spoken over time about everything from
you know Homeopathy to drinking silver
Faith healing old sorts of Medical
Treatments that maybe kind of worked at
one point but there are now better
options compared to out and out scams
Etc one of the things you talk about in
the book is the relation between medical
myths misconceptions and irrational
Health fears and this sense of disgust
that as humans we could say has been
developed or has been bred in or however
you sort of want to say it let's maybe
start there talk a little bit about the
the tendency towards disgust and how it
might predispose people to some of these
medical misconceptions
yeah I think you know discussed as one
of those kind of overlooked emotions um
something that we don't necessarily
think about or talk about a lot
um but oh you know some psychologists
would say that it's one of the basic
human emotions it seems to be Universal
at least the feeling of disgust
um you know there are certain particular
signs of disgust that people around the
world give you know that kind of
squinched up face
um you know kind of it spelling
something out of your body like yeah
like eighty percent of the way to
gagging we might say
exactly exactly and that's something
experience that feeling of being
discussed but in terms of what things
are considered disgusting that's really
kind of up for grabs culturally so that
is something that we we tend to learn as
we grow up so there may be something
where humans as a species have evolved
the sense of disgust probably as a
protective mechanism because a lot of
the things that disgust us are things
that could hurt us right things that
could make us sick for example
um so you know we we learn uh we teach
most of our children around the world
you know not to eat their poop and you
know maybe as babies they they're not
disgusted by poop and they'll stick
their hands right in it but we we you
know we teach our kids to be disgusted
by the smell and and appearance of poop
and most of us around the world get that
at some point in our lives so
um but there are a lot of other things
that vary for you know from place to
place culture to culture
um especially when it comes to things
like food so every culture has some food
that it thinks is delicious and that
other cultures think is totally
disgusting yes so that's so it's
relative so there are things that
um are pretty universally disgusting
those tend to be the things that could
hurt us or make us sick
um and then there are other things that
are just
you know we decide basically that
something is disgusting and something is
not disgusting and so then what's the
connection from that to the medical
myths and misconceptions yeah
you know strong aversion to certain
things
um that means that it can really kind of
guide our decisions and shape our
thinking about things and a lot of the
things that were disgusted by
um involve our bodies you know a lot of
things involving bodily functions
um you know all of our bodily secretions
and excretions
um Blood Sweat tears you know it's not
these are things that you don't
necessarily
um
you know they're very intimate and
they're generally considered disgusting
if they're coming from a stranger right
sure
um so we're not necessarily disgusted
um so much by our own body fluids and so
forth but we're certainly disgusted by
uh those of strangers and so when you
think about you know some of the
different kinds of
um Medical
Treatments and products things that
people are trying to sell to us it's
very easy to play into that sense of
disgust for example there's a huge
industry built around the idea of
detoxifying our bodies yes purifying
cleansing all of these things are
basically meant to make us less
disgusting we all want to be less
disgusting right we all want to have
um this idea of being you know clean and
pure but
when it comes down to it you know a lot
of these things are playing on our
disgust of our of our bodies or other
people's bodies
um and really are not selling us
something that's real you know uh again
you know it's easy to play on that
disgust and say like oh this is going to
detoxify you yeah
um and and that sounds good and if we
see for example if you you know there
are
um
certain kinds of sweat therapy that that
uh people are selling really hard and
the idea is that you can sweat out the
toxins and if people see something
coming out of their bodies it feels like
satisfying it feels like you're getting
something bad out
um yeah I've told stories of uh I don't
do it often because I find it painfully
awkward but I've had like professional
massages before and the massage goes
great and at the end they say you know
the massage will loosen a lot of the
toxins in the body so you should drink a
lot of water and I'm thinking wait a
second so the water is processed and the
kidney what's the mechanism here that's
going on but it's sort of that same idea
where it's like that sounds it sounds
generally good yeah like I mean that I I
could kind of go for that you know
Jonathan height has written about the
connections between disgust and
political leanings and predispositions
and I'm I'm wondering whether when it
comes to medical myths misconceptions
quack cures and openness and this sort
of thing whether there are other maybe
personality traits or whatever that that
we may be able to overlay on whether
it's politics or upbringing or whatever
the case may be yeah yeah I mean
definitely people there's a range in how
easily disgusted people are some people
are very sensitive to disgust and are
very easily triggered to feel disgusted
others not so much I've seem to have a
pretty high tolerance for disgust for
example because I write about gross
things yes
um but you know a lot of people don't
and there have been some studies like
what you're referencing that link those
traits how easily disgusted you are to
various other kinds of opinions that we
form and so some in general
um and I don't want to make this any
kind of hard and fast rule but
some Studies have found a connection
between people who are more easily
disgusted and people who tend to be more
conservative political leaning yes
um and it kind of makes sense if you
think about the idea of um you know that
a person who is
very
um easily triggered to feel discussed
might be kind of sensitive and afraid of
things that could cause that feeling and
so things that are different things that
are outside
um you know may be more triggering to
some people than to others
um I think the same kind of thing
happens
you know perhaps with these kinds of
um Health beliefs and misconceptions
um some people seem to be just more
sensitive and more triggered by the idea
of being contaminated
by something
um by you know things that are dirty
and that can also be likewise that can
be played back into politically you know
I one of the interesting things about
this that you're making me think of is
you know there's a lot of I think we can
all understand how
if indeed this higher sense of or this
more easily triggered disgust aligns
with political conservatism we could see
how that might make people against
immigration right we hear stories about
I mean Tucker Carlson once overtly said
immigrants make make the country dirtier
and poorer that's literally something
that you would be disgusted by the dirt
that he said okay that that one's super
clear it's been interesting to see with
the pandemic
you would think germs around me you
would you would think that with a more
easily triggered disgust response the
right would have been more sensitive to
the idea of the germs of covid but for
political reasons and for other reasons
it hasn't actually been the case
right yeah I think that's an interesting
point too
um you know but disgust can cut a lot of
different ways and you know we have to
remember that it can be discussed can
also be weaponized right uh you know it
can be turned against certain groups of
people like you were saying it's often
turned against immigrants saying oh
they're diseased and dirty
um and they're coming in here and
they're contaminating our population in
some way yes
um you know the same kind of thing can
happen with covid where there's you know
marginalizing of certain groups because
they're seen as the cause
um you know so we saw that with with
Asian Americans
um earlier in the pandemic and so forth
um and so you know I think that the
disgust can be weaponized in whatever
way is convenient for a particular you
know political groups interests
so sometimes you get things that are
sort of nonsensical you know where it
seems like people are really acting
against their own best interests yeah or
even their predispositions but
interestingly there was a sense of
disgust about the masks by some of the
folks who did not see right the feeling
of the mask and it's restricting my
breathing and I'm rebreathing My Own
carbon dioxide related to this does
one's willingness to accept a medical
myth treatment you know scam treatment
or whatever the case may be relate to
how disgusted or put off they are by
whatever it is they are trying to treat
if that makes sense in other words
when you maybe learn more about
something you would be less likely to
fall for the misinformation and the
quack cures
necessarily hard data
and um
I will cite an example of
um kind of a more extreme version yeah
so for example people who are already
easily
um sensitized or disgusted by insects
and afraid of uh you know the people
some of us are totally freaked out by
insects or spiders
um some of us you know
not so much
um there's a condition called delusions
of infestation that I have um
have worked on for for several years now
and
um it's it's really upsetting it's where
people develop the idea that insects
um or other small creatures have in have
literally infested their bodies right
and and it often starts with something
real like an itch it could be as simple
as a skin condition that's causing an
itch but because people some people are
already
kind of worried about insects or just
sort of more prone to to feel discussed
about insects if they happen to see an
insect in the environment they may make
the connection that oh I think that's
what's going on here I think that I've
got these insects attacking me right and
so I think that's kind of an extreme
example of where someone who maybe is
already kind of predisposed to a certain
kind of of disgust or feeling about
about insects you know may be more
likely to develop this
extreme delusion which can be
you know completely devastating where it
takes over people's lives and you know
their lives really become about trying
to prove to everyone else yeah that this
infestation is real yeah my dad's a
psychiatrist and he's he's dealt with
that and talked to me about it some
sometimes that that does respond quite
well to medication interestingly enough
now the interesting thing is that
relates to something else I've said
before which is you know we've talked a
lot about conspiracy theories on the
show yeah and we'll sometimes say you
know how does someone fall into
is it flat Earth or is it you know more
recently with relation to covid stuff
about vaccines how is it they end up
with that as opposed to something else
and very often it's sort of
environmental and Circumstance
circumstantial it's listen because of
the media environment and the people
that they're around and where they live
they're into does injecting bleach cure
covid as opposed to something about the
bilderbergs or flatter so there's like
an invite but they are predisposed
generally to this type of thinking it
seems that with some of the things
you're talking about there might also be
a similar idea where it's not I mean I
don't know it seems that someone who
falls into what you just described about
the insects would be predisposed to
something else if it was environmental
or or around them culturally
right exactly
exactly kind of what psychologists call
magical thinking yes
um you know we none of us are perfectly
logical beings and so we all have these
kinds of beliefs and misconceptions
going on all the time
um about something
about something and you know magical
thinking it can be um you know
psychologists talk about the the law of
similarity and the law of contagion
um which relate to disgust because you
know the law of similarity says the
image is the object and so that's the
that's the kind of thinking that makes
for example
um
burning an effigy uh a very powerful
statement because it you know in our
minds deep in our lizard brain somewhere
it really feels like when you burn the
symbol of the person you're harming the
person it's it's what makes uh voodoo
doll satisfying to stab and it's also
related to disgust it's what makes
poop-shaped chocolates not a big hitch
right right because we associate the
disgusting thing of poop with the
chocolate even though the chocolate is
perfectly fine to eat
um and so you know those kind that kind
of thinking can come in to our basically
our beliefs about health and wellness
and and all of these things as well and
and certainly I think that that
indicates something about our belief
systems more broadly and so uh certainly
I think it makes sense to me that
um you know there there are these kind
of deeper reasons in our thinking that
we're all vulnerable to why we might be
susceptible to certain myths and
misconceptions and then our environments
and our society you know our culture the
people that we're around shape the
details of those things the book is Gory
details Adventures from the Dark Side of
science we've been speaking with the
book's author Erica engelhop who's a
journalist living in Washington D.C
Erica really appreciate your time and
insights today
thank you so much great to be on
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I want to
talk a little bit more about Steve Ducey
Steve Ducey is one of the three hosts of
The Fox News Morning Show Fox and
Friends alongside alongside Ainsley
Earhart and Brian kilmead and Steve
Ducey over the last couple of weeks has
had a few sort of Off Script sane
moments where he will interject some
reality into the propaganda that is Fox
and Friends and his co-hosts don't
really seem to like it earlier this week
I played for you a clip of Steve Ducey
trying to explain to his co-host hey you
know there is this thing called the the
crime fraud exception in the law and if
you understand it you understand a lot
of what's going on with these 34 felony
counts against Donald Trump and his his
co-host did not like it Steve Ducey went
off script again when he pointed out
Trump really shouldn't be talking about
the judge's family and the prosecutor or
the judge on social media it's really
not appropriate to be doing that and
Brian kilomet again just kind of rolls
his eyes and says oh trump it was a
really great speech that Trump gave
something is up with Steve Ducey and he
seems to be trying God bless him uh take
a look at this and one of the last speak
and one of the point before we go uh one
of the last things that Lucas reported
on this morning is prosecutors yesterday
during the indictment uh brought up to
uh Trump and his team
the threatening post that Donald Trump
made he posted on true social uh there
would be death and destruction would
follow if uh he were charged and the
judge uh warned him and his attorneys
make sure that doesn't happen six hours
later at Mar-A-Lago the judge was
attacked the judge's wife and the
judge's daughter the judge's daughter
wound up on true social and a bunch of
social media sites yesterday because she
works for a consulting firm that did
work for Hunter rather Hunter Biden or
the Biden Harris he's trying he's
struggling with a cough he's struggling
to read his notes he's mixing up names
but he's trying he's saying Trump was
told don't go after yeah don't don't do
these inflammatory posts and then he's
attacking the judge the judge's family
and the prosecutor and and Brian
Kilmeade is not pleased with this uh
campaign if you go on their website we
were scrolling through it yesterday they
they represent a lot of Democrats a lot
of Progressive Democrats
very bad look to attack the family he
said these he just mentioned that they
are attack Alvin Briggs attacking him
his wife posted something negative about
him and the daughter works for Democrats
so see Brian Kilmeade says it's fine oh
there seems to be an agenda he didn't
say attack the family he mentioned them
in a speech I thought his speech was
tight last night
we all watched that speech live it was a
tight speech Trump rambled incoherently
about his normal list of Grievances and
seemed to be focused rather than on the
crimes that he has been formally accused
of on his other potential crimes for
which he's not yet been accused and then
abruptly wrapped it up by saying make
America great again even though the
country's under a dark cloud not exactly
a tight speech I believe how tidy was to
the problem a lot of support it seems
like boom boom boom this is what I'm
doing this we're going here's the
problem with our country gotta run and I
like that he did it in Florida he's like
I'm getting the heck out of New York
yeah Yep they're sitting in New York by
the way as they say the good thing he
got the hell out of here this place
sucks so listen I don't I don't know
what's going on with Steve Ducey it
really is I'm not speculating that oh he
has seen the light or he hasn't but he's
pretending because of this reason or
that reason or someone's in his ear I
don't have any speculation as to what's
going on what I can tell you is what I
see
three or four times over the last
several weeks and twice this week Steve
Ducey has tried to introduce some
reality some cogent analysis of the real
world
to his co-hosts and they just basically
steamroll right over it and say
everything's fine Trump's speech was
tight he wasn't really threatening he
was just mentioning oh all these people
who are against me are biased and on and
on there might be some story here you'll
remember with Shepard Smith at Fox News
you started to see little bits and
pieces of this inkling that something
was not there was trouble in Paradise so
to speak and next thing you knew Shep
was gone from Fox News uh I don't know
what's up with Steve Ducey his son also
works Peter Ducey for Fox News but it is
certainly interesting to see let's go
now from Steve Ducey to Harris Faulkner
Harris Faulkner has become an
interesting character on Fox News Harris
Faulkner has become one of the greatest
Trump Brown nosers and Defenders on Fox
News and that's why it's particularly
interesting
that her review of Trump's speech
Tuesday night at Mar-A-Lago was not
exactly glowing now she does sort of Try
by the way this is not an image of
Harris Faulkner that this is this is a
this is a guy Harris Faulkner is a black
woman and this is
um this is a man here uh you'll see her
in a moment
she can't effusively praise the speech
but she's kind of trying to defend it
and the point here is when even Harris
Faulkner is this lukewarm you know that
it's not very good and post is a weird
day never thought I'd see it but here we
are
kapon with what you're saying is right
where Trump went from Mar-A-Lago last
night and that is you know he didn't
call it a whiff I'm gonna call it one oh
she's calling it okay interesting Alvin
Bragg and I don't did you see how
someone's pointing that's very very
strange
someone's pointing almost like they want
the camera only on Harris Faulkner
during this speech that's very
interesting those those pans that pop up
follow the whiff I'm gonna call it one
when we see Alvin Bragg there before all
the reporters and they're pressing why
now and what new evidence and he's
dodging and weaving and his injuries
were terrible they were terrible but he
kept talking so I mean it was just like
it was like nothingness coming out of
his mouth when you see that
Trump didn't stop there it didn't pick
up there where he went was but they'll
still they'll still be coming for me so
let me tell you what's coming I guess
he's saying the brag press conference
was a whiff it's so hard to know what
she's talking about Pike and I always
find it interesting and I did last night
for somebody to lay out a case before
you of how your enemies are coming to
get you to lay out the other cases get
ready they're going to keep coming and
here are the holes in the next one
that Telegraph said he's not so worried
about this one not getting too far ahead
of it they still have to make motions by
August there's a date in August and of
course they want to push this to
December 4th but maybe it won't ever
happen
maybe we won't ever get to trial or
court or anywhere else with this case
but what we do know is he's playing
again the role of someone who wants to
solve the problems of the country okay
actually so this is this is actually
much more delusional than I thought
talked about that he he mentioned the
things that Americans are going through
and at the same time don't think that
they're not going to come get me again
and again and again as they always do as
they did today because I'm trying to
save the country it was interesting it
was short he read the Proctor he left
from a political messaging standpoint
though all right well I guess I mean I
don't know it's the
first of all wasn't reading from a
teleprompter bad he showed up he read
the prompter and he left Trump spent
years saying that Obama reading from a
teleprompter was some form of cheating
and dishonesty and Fox News spent years
agreeing that Obama reading from a
teleprompter is dishonesty then Trump
used a teleprompter his entire four
years and then used one on Tuesday night
and now listen he showed up he did what
he had to do he read off of his prompter
and he left the the real Point here
though is the idea that Trump described
to Americans the things that Americans
are going through Trump talked about the
National Archives classified documents
hush money payoffs a perfect phone call
Ukraine these are the issues that
Americans are going through that's an
extraordinarily who hasn't been indicted
for 34 felonies let's all come together
as Americans so listen I think Harris
Faulkner knows it wasn't exactly a
titillating performance that people were
expecting Trump with fire he's sort of
low energy while very sweaty and visibly
confused read his speech off the
prompter it was the standard set of
grievances we've been hearing at every
rally and nobody was particularly
impressed with it outside of the Fox
News bubble one guy who was clearly
desperate that night
seemingly knowing how poorly it went was
Trump himself because he ended up doing
something he doesn't often do Trump
turned to God
Donald Trump joined an emergency prayer
call after his Mar-A-Lago speech which
came after his arrest he was joined by
Michelle Bachmann and referred to our
beautiful Christianity which he says I
guess is under attack folks if Trump is
turning to prayer and to God you know
that he's scared and that is indeed the
vibe I get here the audio quality is of
course terrible Trump says we are losing
our religion he says that's me in the
corner no okay he we're losing our
religion and he's desperate I guess for
donations money and prayer take a listen
being discriminated against as a
religion we're being discriminated by
the way I have not doctored the audio to
make it worse it's genuinely this bad it
[Music]
is exciting very hard for uh for the
people of our country but I'm very
exciting very hard for people of
relationships
God people that believe in faith this
it's an honor to have so many and that
was a cough coughing is really common on
these prayer calls my friend John McCall
uh as you know we're going through a
fake uh investigation That's What It Is
by radical left
I believe actually have to hate our
country but we're winning we had a great
day today actually because it turned out
to be the ham and it's turning out to be
that and we have others down the line
but we're we've been winning them for
eight years now ever since we came down
the golden escalators they call it a
Trump Tower
things that have always remained solid
on that is our faith our religion our
Christianity our beautiful Christianity
and uh and all two or maybe it was three
of the Corinthians that Trump knows the
thing
people I know who can't be no greater
calling than what do you do and one of
the people on the line was Paula White
the woman who was in that insane viral
religious video where she's going and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and then she starts speaking
in tongues she says or something like
that that's one of the great people on
the call that Trump very much respects
honestly he sounds more desperate for
donations and money than he does for
prayer and of course maybe the country
wouldn't be less and less religious over
time if it weren't for the fact that the
people most loudly demanding the return
of public religion are absolute lunatics
wanting to completely break down any
kind of separation between church and
state this wasn't even as bad as it got
Michelle Bachmann the former Minnesota
congresswoman uh was on the emergency
prayer call and she wants uh to beseech
God or wait or to beseech I never know
who they want to be Siege but anyway
here she she weighed in as well
would you declare Donald J Trump
innocent oh father would you free Donald
Trump from his trouble yeah and our
troubles here in America oh Lord would
you have mercy on Donald J Trump and
America and would you hear this prayer
tonight from your people
won John
J Trump's reputation right
[Applause]
okay okay all right and she just went on
from there this is nuts folks this is
totally nuts and uh this I I don't know
how many donations this is going to
generate for Trump but maybe it will
generate some prayers and we'll see sort
of how effective those are we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's a caller complaining
about the time that we do the show each
day
hey David I'd like to know why um
you can't do your show same day in the
afternoon
um so that it's more up to date and that
you're not reporting yesterday's news
period
yeah listen
um we
no matter what time we do the show
someone has a problem with it we
actually used to do the show later in
the day we used to film more like three
or four o'clock and then it would go out
by like seven or so and what that led to
is that many of our affiliate stations
couldn't air it until the next day and
the first YouTube clips would publish
around seven or eight but then more of
the clips wouldn't publish until the
next day with the podcast people who go
to the gym in the morning or afternoon
in the afternoon more likely they would
write and they'd say you know David I go
to the gym at three four five six the
podcast isn't out till seven or eight so
I'm not hearing it until a full 24 hours
later people didn't like that there's
always some issue but the bottom line is
as follows think of all the platforms
we're producing for
and genuinely to get the show out the
fastest what we found is we record in
the very early afternoon late morning
early afternoon the audio podcast is out
by 2 30 PM Eastern usually that's still
11 30 a.m in the west and that really
feels pretty good without dealing with
this like starting to bleed over into
the next day thing remember also that as
a member you can get the full commercial
free audio or video feeds usually by
like 3 P.M Eastern that's noon on the
west coast so that's the schedule I get
it's not a perfect schedule for
everybody we have some stations that say
we'd like to run it at two but you don't
get it to us till three okay so those
stations have to run the show the next
day we're doing the best we can given
that we have an audience across so many
different time zones usually it's a
combination of stories from the later
half of the previous day and that
morning I mean on today's show there's
stuff that happened this morning that is
on the show so I don't even agree with
the idea that we're like a day behind
but certainly when Trump's Mar-A-Lago
speech is at 8 30 PM that's going to be
on the next day's show it's sort of
inevitable when when Trump doesn't get
out of his arraignment until almost 4
P.M it's very tough to have that on that
day's show we review it the next day and
one other thing I'll say it's not the
end of the world to give a little bit of
space particularly with stories where
you want to get as many of the details
included and correct in the show so I
feel pretty okay with the schedule right
now always open to hearing thoughts from
others we've got a great bonus show for
you today we'll talk about the Bud Light
boycott from the right wing it's a wild
wild one we will talk about a new North
Carolina North Carolina lawmaker
switching parties and we will talk about
a judge ordering Stormy Daniels to pay
Trump another 120 Grand in legal fees
what is that about does it have anything
to do with the arrest from this week no
it doesn't but we will talk about it on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access
foreign